[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off the record
where we talked about what are we today
we got Laura Laura welcome to the show
thank you our fans are probably
wondering who is this lady how do you
spell Lauren hello ry an and you know
are you gonna Y in there yeah but I know
also see there's a lot of different ways
because I know a lot of ways where it's
like are you are you in we did a whole
conversation about how this Spokane yeah
I actually it's not even legally spelled
that way but it allows me if I ever want
to run for president no one would no one
would ever find my internet [ __ ] let me
go back to my legal name well unless you
replay this I'm not gonna tell you what
my legal spelling would you would you
have every combination what I write I
would you run I would have now I like
hate politics mmm before like when you
were like in third grade you mean I was
a president in seventh grade oh that's
it do they hate you oh you lunch lady
because I made him wear a hairnet you
must have been really out of control
treasurer in seventh grade so did I you
did yeah is you in no me neither I'm in
our principal held like a losers party
we got called out of class I mean like
they had like little dinky snack system
that's really nice
no I felt like a [ __ ] loser I didn't
get [ __ ] and I lost I lost and I got no
I'm just proud of you guys for trying
nice don't ever stop trying I'm like I'm
a [ __ ] loser man that's really nice
this participation award why did you
want to be treasurer I just wanted to be
something same treasurer sounds cool it
sounds really cool it's not like
President was way to like you too hard i
molarity contest president is like I'm
not popular I get a fun [ __ ] so I wasn't
popular at all but I knew how to like
campaign to the younger kids and so the
younger kids didn't know my entire
seventh grade class did not vote for me
but it was opened up to the school and
so I went around to the kids class as a
hand out lollipops was like
your school go we were K through seven
but the four grade four through seven
could vote oh that's cool yeah that's
huge so then yeah I just like swindled
all the young uns into voting for why
didn't you become a huge youtuber
because that's what the big youtubers do
oh yeah right just stealing from the
younger generation yeah you just like
cater to eight-year-olds and then you
your channel blows it was a lot easier
when I was younger now I'm like way too
dirty
I don't know feels weird and you're like
talking about getting wasted mmm people
watching your videos or to eat wasted on
Capri Suns at your school you get to
choose if the cafeteria people had a
hairnet
no that was my big campaign I ran on
this car I was like men have you ever
bitten into a cookie during lunch and
found hair in it really should be
wearing
yes I'm Harry lunch ladies so I like
yeah every was like people were like oh
I'm gonna bring in soda machines they
didn't win it was me trying to clean up
the gross cookies but the lunch ladies
were pissed because then they all had to
her hair nuts and they like hated me and
I almost got impeached
cuz I walked out of I walked out of my
pre-algebra class cuz I was mad at my
teacher and then like 15 people walked
out after me they're like you can't do
that we should impeach you and we were
like whoa she's 12 you can in future
this is seventh grade why'd you get mad
at your teacher yeah shaming me she
didn't teach well I was taking a test
and she was like what's taking you so
long and I was like well you didn't
teach us and she was like you don't like
the way I teach you can go to
principal's office
so I did and I'm a knight laughs she was
like anyone else have a problem with the
way I teach you can go to and then
yeah and then they brought in like a
monitor afterward to actually watch how
she taught Wow yeah yeah what sin if
you're watching all the business that's
that's what that's a future leader right
there I walked out on my eighth grade PE
class like a smoke some weed and I got
caught Annie
anyone falling it was it wasn't for like
righteous reasons if I did something
righteous like yeah was the teacher he
saw me walk away but if it was for
reasons like that you know I'd be
learning how to run [ __ ] yeah but you do
run [ __ ] stupid guys about living in a
mud hut no he always forgets he's like
on top yeah oh that's embarrassing
I don't want to that's I'm like those
parents that's like commie Joe man dad
don't call me boss don't call me none of
that [ __ ] mom the Mean Girls mom yeah
anymore
like there's no boss here come on man
yeah but it's like fishing he's out
fishing all day this just made you mom
that's cool
oh she's cool mom
I have [ __ ] sexy legs remember yeah
usually men don't like being called
women that's all okay
maybe weak man but I was raised I was
raised by a mom and my grandma very
strong women my mom's a weak-ass [ __ ]
my grandma oh yeah unfortunately
classics hear me feel good yeah there's
a lot of incest in this company cuz
we're family friends and love is your
dad yeah
yeah what daddy
Oh daddy I thought was a young dad yeah
it's like so confident in this I guess
because I heard it from an older guy
that wanted you to be that one some
people use the word fat either young
people call old people's daddy like oh I
don't know oh they make me got a dad bod
yeah daddy like xan daddy like that I
don't know you came in confident well I
know because I heard it from another
person and then I'm gonna get fat checks
in the freakin commas here we go here we
go with these four other people and then
accept them as fact that's what I do
that's that's everyone does not listen
according to bustle calm Danny is a guy
who who's attractive and fashionable
with swag and sex appeal
Danny key you are so wrong okay so this
guy that makes sense the person that I
heard this that's how you know we're all
that's what what the [ __ ] words means I
just guess you're wise so y'all know
each other long you guys known each
other I think we met through the game
show network for that what was before
that I don't know but you came on
calling in drunk
that was after door three mm door three
was game show networks YouTube channel
and Lauren was a producer and host is
just a make or channel and no it was
game show network like the one on TV
like that actual they started a YouTube
channel and they were basically doing
like game show to esque type she has
said for you yeah her YouTube and then
Steve and I were on this like couples
thing in 2014 or you did room Raiders
yeah we did rumerator yes and we did
with Raiders it was the are like white
trash birds in a room and we did top
list
I'm a t-top oh yeah yeah
I heard a topless yeah it's like it
sounds like topless but it's yeah it's
like a little top five your top five
songs type thing and then I just
remember doing a lot of stuff at the
VidCon Game Show Network thing what was
your guys first impression of each other
that's not when I met you I don't know I
honestly don't remember the few have a
real good man I used to have a [ __ ]
before I gave generic I had a show
basically I I worked at Fox you murmur
Sara Croce yeah so we worked for this
YouTube channel out of Fox where they
were it was a boys club and they were
just like these two girls we need some
YouTube content okay so what can you I
need eight videos and you have a
thousand dollars take it and do whatever
you want we were like alright here's the
deal
we're gonna spent all the money on
alcohol and we're gonna shoot all eight
up says in one day and we're gonna start
sober and then get progressively drunker
and then they let us do that we did like
eight seasons of that show we'd bring in
a guess yeah them get drunk I think some
guests would come in towards the end of
the season and we're just I don't
remember this guest being there so it's
like hot ones but it's drunk ones yeah
like an it was gets progressively
spicier progressively more drunk you
came on yeah that was it I think you
were on like season four or something I
think you were in an earlier episode
yeah I was the I blacked out that season
yeah my husband like twisted his ankle
on set and I didn't know for like four
oh my god even like couldn't walk he was
like I don't know it was my wife care
and I was like I had dancing too High
School Musical in the backyard or
something crazy oh man my liver is
really gonna did you just get back from
patella yeah I shouldn't drink much
how was Coachella it was we've never
been what we always wanted to go it's so
fun it's probably more fun if you know
the music but it's just like a big
Instagram festival oh now it is Graham
Olympics I heard yeah yeah really
Instagram Olympic NZ everyone like plans
their outfits and stuff and let their
Coachella outfits and yeah that's why
just want to be part of it Niki does
the kita dragon circle I thought you
were gonna say Nicky you want you won't
be with the gay people's no I mean just
cuz they're so fabulous like just sure
everything she does she just does it
like 110 percent and I'm like I want to
be your [ __ ] friend and I want you to
make me you see her and Bret do the
choreograph walking on the treadmill
thing I was like that is some scale man
yeah and she just [ __ ] goals full
throttle dude and I'm just like you're
[ __ ] I'm not worthy I was like a big
costume it is yeah I'm just too lazy for
that each other before Instagram got big
I know it's impossible I've been wanting
to go to but I want to go no it's
already too late it's an Instagram I'm
not taking over yeah before it was good
man it was about the music
no it's been around since like since
high school wet in 1999 Rage Against the
Machine was in the first right I think
they got together it was like it goes up
come back towards you up from the Vans
Warped Tour and they're like we're
adults now we gotta go do adult more an
adult festival than they used to go to
Vans Warped Tour I did probably saw you
really yeah well went to the Ventura one
yeah oh you did yeah i would go back
every year
Oh sick I was backstage so just see me
backstage oh it sounds like I was like
what the lucky I was washing in the pit
and getting like all that I did see you
I saw you from the stage wow you're an
[ __ ]
treasurer together
99 no because I was talking to someone
recently saying like yeah I went to like
the third year that they've just started
they made it sound like it was recent no
I don't think it was as big as like
other ones like I remembered there was
something called audio tist ik that [ __ ]
was huge that was like all trance and
then like hip hop and they had jungle
and all kinds of different things so
Coachella was like starting out but they
didn't emphasize that much on electric
music they had more like you know it's
still don't yeah yeah it feels like it
cares you a lot of different genres
yeah
like me as Khalifa was there but so is
Ariana Grande and like the first one it
was like brothers Morrissey yeah machine
yes I think I even had that flyer this
is a second deal does it say in deal
polo field no mobi oh oh yeah alright P
yeah I think I even have my oldest
festival Flyers everywhere that's true
ha Weezer was there I felt real really
yeah they're like 18 year old girls like
losing their [ __ ] to Weezer Weezer is
old there's daddy
I remember when I was in 2nd cut that
was one of the first songs I learned in
second grade like yeah it was second
grade that's a good thing is that all
its they don't feel that old you didn't
feel that you look younger
okay local they're pretty old so old but
that song doesn't go that doesn't scream
90's to me right it's good play it feels
like it came out five years ago the hat
and the hash pipe one be stay relevant
is why is why they continued 1994 yeah I
feel like when you're a musician you
could be a senior citizen but you're
still cool and young Anthony Kiedis man
Red Hot Chili Peppers Oh or Snoop Dogg
he's a grandpa but he's still the
gangster rapper in my mind yeah that's
true
I don't see much not Snoop lion anymore
right he lion he was snoop lion for a
while I wanted to do reggae yeah for a
while I was like DJing parties huh yeah
I feel like you could buy a snoop
appearance you can't hear and you give
that weed literally it's legal now so
that makes sense
I went with this girl that I worked with
that clever Erin Robinson mm-hm she and
I went
we paid full price to sleep in the same
bed in a room in some guy's house what
and this guy was like it was a weird
situation he was like let's go get the
jacuzzi he's like 65
daddy he's like oh my my roommates
moving out it's his ex it's his
girlfriend he called it his roommate cuz
he didn't want us to know that like you
try to get a threesome he came and took
he was like oh this is a good picture
it's Erin and her bathing suit no yeah
I'm gonna take you let me take this
picture for you and he takes it Erin's
like okay here's my phone he's like no
no on mine
photo what just has a photo they're in
her bathing suit on and it was we were
living in his hat we sure the post used
in the book at an Airbnb situation yeah
okay yeah b-but there's definitely
cameras in her oh yeah oh I didn't want
to tell you but he's gonna be so
disappointed he looks at that vision
she's like what's underneath these
clothes yeah it's like people can get
away with charging yeah so much for a
room and he didn't have to change he'd
have to leave his house how far away is
it from the festival we were like 15
minutes that'd be a good investment
property yeah I think that's what
everyone buys stuff Palm Springs now
just for Coachella for the whole month
cuz it's like there's a lesbian festival
called Dinah Shore the weekend before
Coachella and there's Coachella one tour
Teletoon and stagecoach all in April
stagecoach I was the other one I was
trying to say like a country thing yeah
wait where's Burning Man then that's
like it's in the desert Nevada yeah in
Montana in the middle of the desert
isn't it like death something try see if
someone from Burning Man is just like
some dude with the handkerchief
Northwest no and salt and then there's
sand on the bottom of his balls it were
wet
yeah you mean like you mean the chaps
right like their work they don't even
have pants he just he just took his
balls sprayed some water on it and then
sat on Sansa not like stuck to the
bottomless balls yeah I thought her
burning man used to be like a artists
exclusive Instagram Olympics to use that
[ __ ] because there was a artists colony
right here called the brewery and - it
was so real like serious for artists
that they would prep all [ __ ] year
just for Burning Man and guy
would have like floats made out of like
it looks like some what's that movie
with the the [ __ ] World War II or Mad
Mad Max it looks like that [ __ ] you know
like costumes they got it all prepped
and I'm like they take vicious serious
man
that's like a that's like a nerd going
to like the the [ __ ] Renaissance
Faire yeah
Brittany Madden you still have to like
you should go in a group and you have to
like have a tent everything kind of
needs to be really planned and there's
like a community my friend showed me her
like binder like there's a binder of
like community like okay here's what
we're offering the community and here's
where we can get like Oh at this time we
know we can get coffee grinds so what
we're gonna give people is belly dances
or something like every little bind it's
like a very common compound everyone has
like what they're bringing to the table
and then the nard and out and barter
burger yeah it's so very the most
expensive thing is Wi-Fi no I find the
most expensive thing is probably is
probably wet and wet wipes for the but
yeah that's why the most expensive do
you use this oh yeah I just found out
that that's like everyone uses them oh
yeah so you got stank-ass for a maybe
there's nothing in there like - comes
right out let me smell okay yeah I get a
bidet Yahoo yeah
I feel fresh yeah we got how many do you
have to do you got the right thing you
sprayed yourself in the face with it
no really it came out like the different
lives sometimes I'm just like and then
it hits me in the face I learned one new
trick with the bidet oh no what I'm just
scary you come up with so I learn one
new trick
if you you guys never poop and then like
you have like first second third fourth
quarters no like the miners like the
last quarter it just doesn't want to
come out yes
tied game is going into overtime more
fiber and drink more well do all of
those but then when I get fourth quarter
sometimes I have something that's just
in there that doesn't want to come out
yeah
I pull my butt cheeks apart out and then
I spray I spray the pad a into my body
and you guys know how to breathe with
your butt and then the water goes in and
then when I push really hard to the
fourth quarter have that option on our
bidet
it's called vortex I'm gonna press that
that's the that's what it's for
I just breathe and then it sucks it in
and then I push it up and it gets it out
real quick you have to do all that work
yeah full blast is that why the [ __ ]
thing is on full blast sometimes I'm
like people but he's trying to [ __ ]
hit a bloody ass or sure
all right nothing work I tried it before
on your I've never been able to make it
work we work out like it doesn't spray
out oh yeah you're sitting too far
there's like a half second the mix ever
gonna take it should call me in I'll do
it when you press it you gotta wait a
little bit you'll hear do you guys did
you guys adjust the temperature on yours
you could like pay extra to get it warm
warm warm warm yeah we just were just
cold Oh what the [ __ ] yeah life on the
edge that is seats warm
no no ours was like hand installed like
Amazon bought a bidet figured out how to
raise one the one that you just put it
in to hit the whole seat it's not the
whole seat yeah it goes underneath the
seats but it's powerful go to our other
office just to use our bidet we have to
yeah I'll go with you cuz I gotta figure
it out cuz I've not been able to figure
it out we have three in the green room I
mean the right in the set way I forgot
about that well you two you're just a
casual the day's everywhere yeah yeah
you're sitting on one oh I know I don't
know why we don't set one of them I know
we should we live like peasants how we
here clearly I don't know why we just
don't it just I was so confused the
first time I went to party I'm like wait
you guys have all this space like why do
you have we don't like stay here
yeah we don't like stay here so where's
your other office in LA